Engineers in San Diego are working on smart
clothes to cool and heat the human body using
fabric that expands or shrinks in reaction
to temperature.
And 100 million dollars have just been allocated
to use radio telescopes to search for aliens.
Researchers at Duke University connected the
brains of four rats to create a brainet.
After networking the four brains via electrodes
the rats were given tasks in memory storage
and retrieval and the brainet performed better
than individual rats did.
This technology could revolutionize computing,
as well as provide new mental and physical
therapies for stroke victims or people in
comas.
Oregon State University researchers have patented
bacon seaweed.
Created from a strain of red marine algae
this new superfood is packed with minerals
and proteins and has twice the nutritional
value of Kale.
But most importantly when it's fried it tastes
like bacon.
A construction company VolkerWessels hopes
to start building roads out of plastic.
Their proposed idea would be to collect plastic
floating in the ocean and then process it
into sections of road that could be installed
onsite like tiles.
In theory, these roads would be more durable,
environmentally friendly, and easier to install
than asphalt, however concerns over their
safety when in contact with rain or extreme
heat must be addressed before the project
can move forward.
Not to mention the actual cost of collecting
plastics from the ocean.
The Hankook iflex is an airless tire.
Comprised of three solid sections the iflex
promises a smoother ride, more fuel efficient
driving, and it's not only made out of recycled
materials it can itself be recycled.
The tire has actually been in development
for several years but recent advances in the
manufacturing process means they can start
moving past prototyping stages and into performance
and durability testing.
The In-situ Fabricator is a robot that can
lay bricks for construction sites.
Unique in that it is autonomous, the fabricator
can build a 3D map of a construction site
and upload it, which also means that the robot
can navigate the area on its own.
It’s not yet ready for commercialization
though as it needs a human to feed it bricks.
Images of celebrities were used in mind game
experiments to discover how memories are formed.
The researchers would show a subject a photo
of someone like Jennifer Aniston next to the
Eiffel Tower and then monitor which neurons
fired within the brain.
They found that if then just shown an image
of Jennifer Aniston the subject’s neurons
related to the Eiffel Tower would also fire
up, illustrating that neurons change their
firing properties at the exact moment that
a memory is formed.
Basically, they observed learning.
The Stella Lux is a family-oriented solar
car that generates more energy than it uses.
Built to accommodate four people and reach
a speed of 77 MPH (125 KM) the Stella Lux
is able to take its surplus energy each day
and return it to the grid.
In October, it will be competing in the Bridgestone
world solar challenge, and if you pledge of
10,000 euros to the team they’ll fly you
to Australia to take a ride in the car.
A new species of Raptor was discovered in
China and it has feathered wings.
The raptor probably couldn’t fly, so possible
explanations for the wings include for use
in mating displays, protecting eggs, or regulating
body temperature.
The discovery raises questions about the evolution
of wings, and how they may have initially
evolved for purposes other than flying.
Raytheon has created a see-through aluminum
ceramic that is bullet proof.
The substance is half as heavy as traditional
bullet proof glass and is twice as effective
at stopping bullets, and it remains transparent
even after being shot.
So far the armor is only used for battlefield
lenses, or windows over missile sensors, but
could someday allow for even safer windshields.
Buddy is a new companion robot for your home.
He autonomously patrols the house reminding
you of important events, acting as your alarm
clock, turning off your lights when you’re
not around, and alerting you of suspicious
activity.
You can take control of buddy remotely in
order to check on your home, and he can act
as a party photographer, or tutor for your
child.
And he's being built to be a robotic modular
platform that a community could program for
and improve.
Finally mcity, is a city built specifically
for autonomous vehicles.
The types of technologies that'll be tested
out here are both connected so vehicles communicating
with other vehicles even around blind corners
as well as to the infrastructure.
And then various levels of automation all
the way up to fully autonomous.
Will the automated vehicle detect the pedestrian
in the crosswalk and stop?
I’m going to leave you with tangible holograms,
and as always, thanks
for watching.